alors serge la main comme vous êtes
passés pas loin de la mort lors de votre
accident
je vais vous faire une interview
jugement dernier c'est normal
serge lama a dû voler de l'argent dans
le porte monnaie de ta maman quand tu
étais petit jamais il a volé jamais fait
pour piquer de l'argent à ma mère
c'était compliqué vous savez d'été très
province et puis je piquais les sucres
serge lama as-tu copié sur ton voisin en
classe pendant les compos oui as-tu
enfermer des élèves du sexe féminin dans
les cabinets non non mais j'avais déjà
fait une sale manie quand j'étais à la
maternelle ne pas déjà des jeux je
piquais les petites filles avec des
épingles
et serge lama est ce que tu te reprend
pour sa wii ah oui oui serge lama as-tu
par donner à ta mère oui serge lama as
tu déjà été tentée par l'homosexualité
non et j'avais mon meilleur ami qui
était homosexuel et quand comme ça a
marché très mal quand j'étais môme avec
les avec les jeunes filles à jour
j'arrive
et puis je dire j'en ai j'en ai plein
mon je vais me faire payer j'en ai eu
mon mari me dit à mon pauvre caucourt on
peut pas voir toutes les chances en même
temps serge lama as-tu fait l'amour sans
désir de procréer oui quelle honte tu te
reposes irait même que des fois je les
fais volontairement pour ne pas procréer
serge lama as-tu trompette à femmes
et c'est ta dernière chance serge lama
le jugement dernier
six d'entre eux a dit
et avec ma femme c'est entrer au paradis
serge lama as-tu trompeta maîtresse puis
ma femme que serge lama as tu vraiment
fréquenter les petites femmes de pigalle
et ben non non moi je suis plutôt un
type à bourgeoise
oui je suis un peu non sur j'aime serge
lama
tu préfères les femmes mariées oui comme
ça tu les a passionnés de toute la
journée je peux rigoler pas forcément
mariés mais aussi oui d'accord
serge lama as-tu exiger des femmes des
pratiques contre nature
j'ai pas exigée mais j'ai je leur ai
demandé quoi gentiment elles ont dit oui
pas tout
c'était